Hey youtubers it's Charlie. This is going
to be my Doctor Who Episode 5 video. We finally
found out who Maisie Williams is playing,
we finally found out why The Doctor's face
looks exactly like the character Capaldi played
during Series 4 in The Fires of Pompeii, and
I think they're laying seeds for something
really special to happen later on if the opportunity
presents itself. Just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet in new
round of the Doctor Who giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so start
with top five just your biggest one first
meet Maisie Williams playing Ashilda - not
a time Lord but functionally immortal by the
end of the episode I'm sure this will totally
not end badly the reason why this is so exciting
you know not only because of that weird look
that she has at the end because that montages
happening she slowly comes to the realization
of his like new philosophy of it presumably
will find out about in the next episode technically
it's not a two-parter but because her story
is carrying into the next episode I'm thinking
of it as a two-parter there were so many things
that were being teased about her character
just like the offhanded dialogue that the
doctor had premonitions just remembering in
the wrong direction the you start to get the
idea that she's having this sort of River
Song-type arc where like she's remembering
things in the wrong direction like River Song
and The Doctor's timelines move in opposite
directions really just leads and the idea
of her becoming immortal in the cyclical nature
of time but you know of events repeating themselves
overlarge periods of time and you have to
appreciate the way they weave that in really
nicely with the idea of storytelling like
the roles that stories play in mythic culture
Maisie's character explained she makes puppets
to make up stories when people go away to
hopefully bring them back to try and change
the story tell a story to bring a favorable
outcome that something that people still do
today but because this is Doctor Who in the
way Doctor Who plays with reincarnation regeneration
you think that there's like some weird aspect
of this like maybe she has magical powers
of some kind that turns out to not be the
case really the only special ability she has
now is that that chip will never stop repairing
her body which kind of makes it like dalek
technology although it is from the Maia so
hopefully she's not gonna wind up looking
like the daleks in the sewer here or like
the face of Bo like she just keeps going on
and on and on until something really terrible
happens to her body but she can't die the
doctor has that speech at the end mostly to
explain why he gave the second chip to her
so that she could have a companion of her own
but it also sounds a little sinister
too. living forever is more of a curse than
it is a blessing like maybe in helping her
he actually made things worse but on the number
four though, meet the Maia: Doctor Who's newest
race of monsters. if the Odin character look
familiar it's because he looks a lot like Brian
Blessed from flash. He played like the Prince
of the Valkyries. there were a lot of funny
in jokes and this too especially the Benny
Hill stuff all it needed was a Benny Hill
theme and then they actually play the Benny
Hill theme in the episode that that was even
funnier to me but as is explained in the episode
their race just goes around strafing cultures
trying to extract chemicals from the finest
warriors but in a funny way they did the exact
same thing that Maisie Williams character
does they tell a story to try and bring a
favorable outcome there just playacting something
specific to that Viking culture so they went
to another planet that Odin character would
co-opt some character from from that other
races culture did anybody else think of Anthony
Hopkins version of Odin and in the Thor movies
whenever the doctor was making the joke about
the yo-yo see look at him he he can't be Odin,
he doesn't even have a yo-yo somebody
tell Kevin fight he and marvel that they been
leaving the yo-yo bit set of the Thor movies
on the number three though babies are the
finest poets on Doctor Who of course the doctor
speaks baby no surprise there, and of course
the baby is like the most eloquent poetic
person in the narrative. that's a very philosophical
Doctor type moment with Doctor waxes on how
the most innocent things can be the most beautiful
things babies are pure because they haven't
been corrupted yet that's a very common theme
across a lot of literature like children are
the most intelligent people but on the number
two: The Doctor remembers why he chose this face you choose revealed that I felt like
that was very important is gonna go down is
a very important moment in Capaldi's run
you however long goes on, but I don't like
the way they used it. I was really kind of
hoping that he would have chosen this face
as part of this prophecy of the hybrid or
are you took some much more complex part of
the plot line but it turns out to be this
really general thing like: I'm the Doctor and
I save people; really the writers could've used
any small moment to make the doctor realize
that. you guys can let me know in the comments
though: do you feel like they wasted the mystery
of the doctor's face on on this very generic
type of reveal? It's a really great character
moment for the doctor, I just - I feel like the
face reveal was a missed opportunity; they
they could have used it for something even
bigger. finally on my number one WTF moment
Maisie Williams becomes a hybrid. here's the
really important thing about this that we
need to talk about does this have anything
to do with Davros' prophecy of the hybrid.
there was a prophecy on Gallifrey that Davros
referred to: maybe Maisie Williams is
that hybrid. I feel like that would be
amazing because the doctor made it sound like
this prophecy is the most terrible thing ever
like this hybrid must never come to exist.
hybrid Maisie Williams also works with the
metaphor too. Back in the Davros episodes
Missy said each of us is a hybrid. She was speaking
about the balance between enemies and friends
like the hybrid between an enemy and a friend
but I do feel like even if you haven't been
completely satisfied with the Doctor Who
stories and series 9 they've done a really good
job of presenting this hybrid theme across
all the episodes. So we still have seven episodes
left, not including the Christmas special, we
need to see like how this hybrid theme spreads
across the rest of the season but here's another
big question for you guys like what you think about
the way they use previous Doctor Who ideas
in this episode but did you enjoy seeing David
Tennant and all his companions? it's always fun
to see them use clips from old episodes they've
used a lot of audio from classic to another
used a lot of video from new who episodes.
used sparingly can be really awesome and I
think if they do it too much like if they
do this every single episode then it'll get
a little bit old but the big thing to walk
away from this episode is is in wondering
if the doctor created a tidal wave change
in time there. He said it's okay to make ripples
but we're time travellers - we can't make waves.
So I'm just going to move into the Easter eggs now if there
are any that you guys see that that I don't
end up mentioning just write them below in
the comments. the 2000 year old diary comes
out - the second doctor had a diary but it
was like a 500-year-old diary.  So they're just like
slowly upgrading it hopefully we'll see a 3000-year-old
diary at some point I mean I like to believe
Doctor Who can last that long. Good man goes
to war was the first time we heard the doctor
speak baby that was Matt Smith's Doctor which is
funny because everyone called him the baby
doctor because he was so young. the doctor
says reverse the polarity of the neutron flow
right out of the third doctor. there's been
so much Capaldi that's gone back to the third
doctor so many references to the first three
doctors just in general. There's actually been a
bunch of episodes of the doctors got into
swordfights there's sea devils, the mask of Mandra
Gora, the androids of tara, and the king's demons.
I really like the nod that he gave to Clara
when she raised her hand too, like, oh yeah you've
been traveling with me, of course you use a
sword at some point. one of the most fun things
about Doctor Who is the adventures that we
don't see, like when they open the episode they're
talking about saving the flow CNs that's a
whole adventure that will probably never see
like you just have to conjure things up in
your imagination as they talk about them.
I guess that's really where like the 'big finish'
stuff comes in, wwhere the audio dramas come
in, to fill those gaps. speaking of which, I
think I mentioned it in my last Doctor Who video
video but just in case I didn't, they're actually
making audio dramas for the War Doctor, John
Hurt's War Doctor. So if you ever wanted to hear
a bunch of war Doctor stories like full-blown
stories they're going to be making that box
set real soon. so don't forget next week kind of
part two of this episode technically it's not
a two-parter but Maisie Williams is back playing
the same character, and it's like a continuation
of this story. so be sure to subscribe to get
that video and that reminds me congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner pancake power
you and a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back and my channels
and get your contact info and slightly related
news, there's actually been a bunch of game of thrones
news the last day or so so I might do that video
next and then do my flash arrow Q&A so just
stay tuned for all that stuff. While you guys wait,
you can click here for all my Doctor Who series
9 videos in case you missed that I actually
posted the game of thrones New York comic
con panel from last week you can click here to watch that.  Thank you so much for watching, let's high five and I'll see you
guys tonight!